what up reject nation's strongest
avengers have from new rockstars
john coygendro who by the way i know i mentioned
this last video koi's comic corner is a segment
that we are starting up here on the channel
video's supposed to be out last weekend
but uh it took me longer to edit than i than i
anticipated but it'll be out this week i promise
my brevity i promise coy it'll be out it'll
be a comic expert here to help break down
the thor trailer right after the reaction
guys if you can leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also subscribe click the
notification bell to get notified when koi's
comment corner is up here on the channel and
lastly this video is sponsored by better health
a company that we are very excited to partner
with because all three of us are therapy people
like all those other people who don't do real
therapy we know therapy up in here mentally
therapy taught us to be
this way about other people
and it's your brain brain idiot more on that after
the reaction but yeah let's watch this trailer
kids get to popcorn out let me tell
you the story of the space viking
thor odinson he was no ordinary man he was a god
for the 500th time thor set off on a new journey
nice well he got in shape
he went from dead bod to god
and after all that he reclaimed his title as the
one and only four oh spook too soon jane whoa
oh [__] son god where are you next girlfriend
what's the family three four years
eight years seven months and six days
changing busy sensing
she looks great man the only ones who
god is themselves
impressive what you did back there
yeah damn she's my first bad guy
you never forget your first
zeus
worth fighting for
wow
oh give me that monochrome all day let's
see who you are i take off your disguise
you flick too hard damn it
eventually great
oh wow that is so easy-tastic what a stunning
second hearing christian bale's american voice oh
you know they're gonna say like sword like oh that
looks yeah the inverter looks amazing yeah dude
that was so freaking epic i think we all loved
it look koi has to get it you guys go 30 seconds
we should get to you first okay so really quick
we're from better help and then we'll get to koi's
breakdown thank you better help so in honor of
may being mental health awareness month today's
video is sponsored by the folks at betterhelp.com
the goal of this month is to raise awareness about
mental health and as two people have been in talk
therapy couples counseling john individual talk
therapy for the better part of a decade this is
actually a topic that we take pretty seriously
and the month is also about fighting stigma
and providing support to anybody who might be
struggling with their own experience so through
better helping gain access to customized online
therapy that includes video phone and even live
chat sessions with one other 20 000 therapists
you don't even have to see anyone on camera if
you really don't want to and while traditional
offline therapy is great it can also be pretty
expensive and better help is not only affordable
but they also offer financial aid and accept hsa
benefits part of how it works is you'll fill out
a questionnaire upon signing up so betterhelp can
assess your special needs and match you with your
first therapist within 48 hours you can schedule
secure sessions with your therapist and exchange
unlimited messages with complete confidentiality
so this mental health month if you or someone
you know is struggling please share with
them better help and feel free to use our
special link betterhelp.com real rejects to save
yourself 10 on your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com real rejects take care of yourselves
this month guys and the rest of the months while
you're at it every month every month as every day
as much as you can koi get to it okay so there is
almost definitely multiple thor's here i think it
almost confirms a lot of the rumors i think that
gore might actually be systematically taking out
thor's in multiple universes we're living in this
multiversal age and all gods must die is so iconic
from the comic books it looks like he is able to
manipulate reality in at least the black and white
sense which is very much from the asadra beast art
from the jason aaron run of the thor comic books
now i do think we're gonna see the necro sword
invert time i think the necro sword is gonna cause
a bit of a reality manipulation which i think is
gonna allow him to take out gods with whatever
power set he has now i do think we're gonna see
a blend of greek mythology north mythology all of
these things mixing with the mcu and that would
be a fun way to tie in different mythos in the
different universes while we can play with the
universe eight 833 or 616 or whatever universe
we got we also have the idea to play with these
different mythologies so i think we're not only
getting that but i think that might be why it's so
important we have jane foster as the mighty thor
in our universe anchoring us to the mjolnir of our
universe with a god that is unique to our space
i think there are multiple odin sons but i think
there is only one mighty thor and i think that's
why it's going to be really essential to tell this
story this way i also think we're going to see a
lot of really interesting hijinks with a lot of
mythical characters like the goats i think we're
going to see a lot of stuff with the guardians of
the galaxy being confused about the multiverse
i think they're going to be a bit of our eye
line to understand that there are multiple thor's
and most of all i think all of this is going to
be very approachable through the guys of 80 sexy
hemsworth yeah definitely gore the god butcher to
me is a character that simplicity is his strength
i think a lot of people are upset that he looks
like an action figure that looks like christian
male i think that's the power of this character
he's a guy that is pale nondescript and has a
necro sword and has billowing white robes what is
terrifying is the performance what is terrifying
is what he's capable of what is terrifying is that
this is a person that simplicity allows them to
be kind of undermined like you don't expect a lot
from a guy that looks like christian male when
you're in a world of colorful titans it's not a
coincidence that this is the most colorful marvel
film to date and you've got a character that
takes away the very essence of color you've got a
character that takes away the very essence of life
a character who literally wants nothing but
destruction which is why i think tyke has been
saying this might be one of the greatest marvel
villains to date i think his lack of colorful
flavor his lack of versatility the fact that he's
the emperor palpatine of this whole world the fact
that he has one goal he's not nuanced like thanos
he's not like killmonger when you identify with
them he all gods must die really quick though
this is all a teaser for how uh koi's coming
so it's easy
so this guy you know with gord of the god
butcher's background involving null symbiote and
all yes i know we have the teaser for the symbiote
being left behind in uh you know no way home
however this is a completely different category
you're dealing with all black you're dealing
with the very origins of symbiote do you think
we will actually have that included in here or
they will just use the aesthetic design do you
think they will actually go to the history of
that you think we'll explore the true origins of
it i think a lot of the strength of the marvel
cinematic universe is that they retroactively
allow whatever they want to i guarantee you they
plant seeds here that they can choose or choose
not to retroactively turn into a symbiote so i
think the necrosword is going to be very much
slithery i think it's gonna be very much uh
leaned into that null might be the cause of it
and then if they choose in however many years
tom holland wants to come back for and however
they go from that then they could make this a
thing when you look at the 10-year plan of kevin
feige not only is the strength of the fact that
he looks ahead he also looks in the past he also
goes hey let's make thor dark world very relevant
due to end game let's do all these things so i
guarantee when they look at something like null
you have the seeds planted because this is all
donnie kate's joint donnie kate's an incredible
writer writing hulk right now writing thor right
now all of those things are going to establish a
world that they can pick and choose from with the
benefit of hindsight now imagine that everything
he did but you know just wait way more editing
and uh you know with more inserts and graphics
and stuff i just wanted to make sure you guys
know how i'm just rushing to get this up right
here buy some comments and most importantly
the same amount of input from both of them
yeah all right koi look i know you got a jet do
you know what you see yourself on here i mean i
i figured out i'm like hello he's got tickets
to some place and he's running late already
he's waiting for us i wanted to stay this is
awesome i love you guys anybody like real rejects
what do we do uh and yeah with this trailer what
i thought was really great about it was getting
more of the relationship with natalie portman
and chris hemsworth what excites me about this
is the last time that we saw chris hemsworth and
natalie portman together the portrayal of thor
was so different much more brooding much more
serious we haven't had a chance to see natalie
portman interact with this version of thor
one who is a much more of the comedic chris
hemsworth style and it looks like we're also
going to get a reinvention of natalie portman
as jamie foster to have more of her sense of humor
shine as well if you've ever seen interviews with
natalie portman or some of the comedy she's done
she is also exquisite at comedy she really knows
comic timing very very well and in terms of a lot
of what koi was also riffing on when it comes to
gore the god butcher you know like manipulating
reality one thing that i was thinking about was
how they brought it up again in avengers end game
due to the circumstances but in you know thor the
dark world she's infected with the ether you know
and that deals with reality stone you know warping
reality so i wonder if in some way the ether
being in her is a big part of what allowed them in
reality for her to manipulate itself into this
situation where she can now be the mighty thor
i think they would probably somehow hook that in
to here they might actually have more chemistry
chris hemsworth and natalie portman here than they
did in the other thor movies simply because they
get to be more of themselves but john we got
other good things in here you know we had zeus
let's talk about some stuff i just really like the
film styles on display here because if there's one
thing that i think uh you know is sort of point of
contention about ragnarok for a lot of people is
that they did go full comedy they go full garish
and for some people that was a bit too much and
i think that this does an interesting job and
suggests a tempering of that style and aesthetic
where yes you'll have the humor obviously but
gore by contrast looks directly like an injection
of intensity and of monstrosity you look at the
design here it evokes things like the orcs and the
urukai from lord of the rings as well as obviously
the comic book art that inspires gork i think that
that's an easy way without going too far into
like extreme content that you can add something
that's very chilling and very hardcore to temper
out some of the stakes so that maybe this might
appeal further to the people who didn't like it
being so comedy oriented with tyka's first outing
with ragnarok so i feel like this too represents
an interesting and an exciting growth for him
on this scale bringing in both his comedic chops
which we know he has in spades and then also the
more intense the more heavy like goer looks like a
natural horror yeah it looks like an earth-shaking
villain and the i i am a sucker for monochrome
and the look of those moments where they're out
and it's just floating debris and there's no color
really feel a like quintessential comic book art
and b like something really fresh and interesting
and visually bold that the marvel cinematic
universe can now introduce i'm rooting for this
to be an expansion on taika's film chops as well
i'm glad you talked about zeus zeus looks really
fun and great and i'm glad russell crowe is here
naked chris hemsworth always a plus i bet
that blur will not be there in the movie
yeah i bet there's a good new rock stars
trailer breakdown to check out but guys
thank you so much for being here we got a rush
to get the stuff for you all we'll see you soon